bonjour à tous aujourd'hui à faire le
test d'un produit on va tester un
stabilisateur pour voir ce qui marche
c'est un bout de bois mal c'est le feu
you take c'est le gumball qui s'appelle
spg l'idée c'est qu'effectivement si
vous avez votre smartphone tout vous
voulez film ils devraient tous d'un
petit peu le smooth vous pouvez prendre
le stabilisateur et s'écoulent en rien
je bouge des places pour regarder c'est
ce pays où tech est à la hauteur par
rapport à un marché qui commence
vraiment à développer il ya plein de
produits il ya plein de produits qui
sont cool on va regarder si celui-là est
cool je vous ai fait plein de clichés
plein de vue plein de plans donc on va
regarder ça et puis à la fin je vous
fais un petit débrief et on va regarder
s'il est cool
oui ou non on n'y va maintenant
[Musique]
rejoindra-t-il mais qu'un galaxy à 8
samsung les derniers modèles de cette
année alors je trouve que dans l'absolu
pour l'instant le feu utah qu'en termes
de prise en main le s p g est pas mal il
fait son boulot au niveau de la
stabilisation il rien à dire je trouve
que maintenant pour l'instant il a un
point un petit peu négatif c'est lorsque
vous voulez le range et que vous voulez
le mettre directement dans sa boîte vous
êtes obligés de redescendre les
paramètres pour les smartphones parce
que vous êtes obligé de régler une
petite bague pour le régler à la taille
de votre smartphone pour qu'ils soient
rééquilibrées l'équilibrage fait pas
tout seul ça c'est un pool points
négatifs ce qui fait que vous êtes
obligé à chaque fois de régler pour le
mettre dans la boîte
c'est un peu moyen ici faut défaire la
bague faut l'être desserrer faut lui
trouver sa position d'équilibré d'un
côté là il est top plus à droite là trop
à gauche trop up florrick allait à peu
près un peu plus par là c'est ça c'est
franchement la galère l'orne à peu près
bon je resserre sans bouger ménages les
macanais
une fois que j'ai calé il est à peu près
un point de vue son frère parce que
chaque smartphone est vraiment différent
niveaux équilibre ensuite il suffit de
l'allumer le connecter en wifi ils se
reconnaissent et là maintenant je suis
bon je peux le piloter je peux le faire
tourner à droite à gauche c'est pas trop
mal fichu sinon donc là je suis en train
de filmer avec regarder la caméra c'est
un peu le bazar et ce qui est bien par
contre activement après c'est la
stabilisation lorsque vous bougez vous
voyez le truc est stabilisé dans sa
tournée un petit peu mais bon c'est pas
hyper des rencontres ça marche bien sur
ya un coup à prendre mais c'est pas mal
alors au final qui fait une taxe stg
comment est ce qu'il est c'est un guide
ball qui est plutôt pas mal qui est très
bien stabilisé qui qui marche bien avec
tous les smartphones vous pouvez régler
votre bague en haut et en bas c'est
assez pratique comme je vous le dis
inconvénients que je vois moi c'est
vraiment le côté de vous dire à chaque
fois je suis obligé de calibrer ici
voilà ça c'est le côté qui est un peu
casse bonbons sinon dans l'absolu seront
ça plutôt pas mal c'est vrai que c'est
bingo ils sont plus en plus pratique
parce que les smartphones on voit sont
stabilisées mais ce n'est pas toujours
idéal d'ailleurs sur smartphone là c'est
pareil d'un galaxy à 8
il est pas mal mais la stabilisation est
pas non plus dantesques c'est pas génial
donc si vous voulez vraiment quelque
chose par des images hyper smooth pour
filmer avoir des trucs qui sont vraiment
bien un petit guide ball comme le fait
you take spg ça marche super bien
d'ailleurs dit moi vous ce que vous en
pensez est-ce que vous avez déjà utilisé
des dean ball pour vos vidéos est ce que
ça pourrait vous intéresser
est ce que vous voyez vraiment l'utilité
ou est ce que vous dites de moi je tiens
la main avec une bonne correction
stabilisation au niveau logiciel ça
suffit marc guillemot tout son
commentaire on reste connectés
si ce game boy vous intéresse je vous ai
mis un lien dans la description
merci beaucoup de regarder la vidéo je
vous dis à très bientôt soyez sages et
moi je suis retourné faire un peu de
luge du skin cailler les miches faisant
valoir à bientôt
[Musique]